Avril 1945,
La Seconde Guerre mondiale se termine à Berlin.
Les combats sont particulièrement violents,
Le monde entier réalise soudain l'ampleur inouïe de ce conflit sans précédent.
Plus de 50 millions de morts.
Jamais une guerre n'avait été aussi meurtrière.
Dans ce chaos,
Les Alliés découvrent, médusés, les camps de concentration.
Le choc est tel,
Que les Américains obligent parfois les Allemands,
À venir voir l'horreur par eux mêmes.
La Shoah,
Les millions de morts des combats.
Certains Allemands jurent, ignoraient tout de ce désastre.
D'ailleurs au procès de Nuremberg,
Face à l'horreur des faits,
C'est également ce que disent certains nazis,
Comme Hermann Goering,
Ici, à gauche.
Pourtant,
Un homme va clamer haut et fort le contraire.
Le Britannique, Elwyn Jones,
Substitut du procureur.
Selon lui, ce cauchemar ahurissant était écrit d'avance.
Les nazis n'ont jamais caché leurs intentions.
Pour ceux qui savaient lire,
Il y avait Mein Kampf,
Les mots issus du cerveau du Führer.
Mein Kampf, littéralement Mon combat.
La bible des nazis, rédigé par Adolf Hitler.
Un livre sulfureux qui aurait conduit au pire,
Comme l'affirme Elwyn Jones.
De Mein Kampf,
Le chemin conduit directement aux fournaises d'Auschwitz,
Et aux chambres à gaz de Majdanek.
Et à l'époque,
C'est justement ce que pensent certains Allemands.
Je me disais, l'histoire l'a prouvé.
Mein Kampf a joué un rôle dans la préparation,
De l'un des plus grands crimes à l'échelle mondiale.
Le contenu du livre est bouleversant,
Parce que c'est son plan d'action.
Alors la Shoah et la guerre étaient-elles écrites dans Mein Kampf ?
D'ailleurs, que raconte exactement ce livre ?
Près d'un siècle après sa première parution,
L'ouvrage continue de diviser.
Ce livre ne devrait plus exister.
C'est le récit de la haine des peuples,
Un chemin fou qui conduit à la perte.
Le tout rédigé par un petit homme qui croit dur comme fer ce qu'il a écrit.
C'est vraiment, évidemment,
Un brûlot antisémite, d'une violence qui vraiment,
Parfois même à la lecture est dur à lire.
Si l'on veut connaître Hitler,
Ses ressorts, ses mécanismes,
On ne peut pas faire l'économie de ce livre.
Voici l'histoire secrète,
D'un des ouvrages politiques les plus vendus au monde.
12 millions et demi d'exemplaires édités avant 1944.
Un livre maudit, issu d'un homme qui incarne le mal absolu.
Un livre interdit dans de nombreux pays pendant 70 ans.
Un livre au destin incroyable.
Tout commence en novembre 1918.
À la fin de la Première Guerre mondiale,
Les soldats allemands rentrent chez eux.
Et parmi ces millions d'hommes,
Il y en a un qui n'accepte toujours pas cette défaite,
Adolf Hitler.
Il n'est alors qu'un modeste caporal sur le point d'être démobilisé.
Adolf Hitler, au lendemain de la Première Guerre mondiale,
Est un parfait inconnu.
Et c'est quelqu'un qui,
À l'époque, il est né en 1889, a 30 ans,
A très peu de perspectives d'avenir.
Ce qui risque d'arriver à Hitler au lendemain de la guerre,
Et ce qu'il ressent, évidemment,
C'est de retrouver la vie qui a été la sienne,
Avant la guerre.
C'est à dire au fond,
Pour dire les choses rapidement,
La vie d'un raté.
Hitler n'a pas de métier, pas d'argent, plus de famille.
Alors il va s'accrocher à ce qui lui reste,
L'armée.
Et c'est là justement qu'un homme va le remarquer.
Le capitaine Karl Mayr.
Il repère des talents,
Qui peuvent alimenter 2 choses.
D'une part, les services de renseignement de l'armée,
Et d'autre part, le service de propagande,
Y compris la possibilité d'avoir des conférenciers.
Karl Mayr engage donc Hitler comme espion.
Sa mission,
Infiltrer le PAD,
Le Parti des travailleurs allemands,
Un parti d'extrême droite.
Et là, Hitler s'y sent particulièrement à l'aise.
Il fait ce qu'on lui a demandé,
Mais il fait beaucoup plus,
Puisqu' à un certain moment, il prend la parole.
Et alors là,
C'est un moment clé,
Parce qu'il découvre ce qu'il ignorait.
C'est son talent d'orateur.
Et c'est à Munich,
Dans des brasseries comme celle ci,
Qu'Hitler devient progressivement le leader du PAD.
Plusieurs fois par semaine,
Il se lance dans des monologues de 2h d'affilée.
Au départ,
Il ne séduit qu'une poignée de militants,
Mais il va finir par captiver des milliers de personnes.
Au début des années 20,
Hitler est un habile agitateur de brasseries.
Mais il n'a aucunement l'intention d'écrire.
En fait, un évènement va changer la donne.
Ce qui se passe,
C'est qu'il y a l'exemple de Mussolini.
Qui a fait sa marche sur Rome et ça donne des idées à Hitler.
Alors en novembre 1923, Hitler va imiter Mussolini.
Il a 34 ans.
Il est à la tête d'un parti qui monte.
Et à ses côtés se tient un héros de la Première Guerre mondiale,
Le général Ludendorff.
À Munich,
Les 2 hommes décident que l'heure est venue,
De prendre le pouvoir par la force.
Hitler et ses troupes interrompent brutalement une réunion,
Où se trouvent le gouvernement de Bavière.
Au milieu de cette réunion,
Hitler fait son apparition.
Des coups de revolver sont tirés au plafond.
Il y a un côté assez putsch d'opérette dans l'opération,
Puisqu'il arrive, il tire un coup de pistolet.
Il fait des grands discours.
À l'époque,
On ne connaît pas encore sa caricature par un Charlie Chaplin,
Mais on imagine que ça ressemble à ça.
Et il menace ceux qui ne veulent pas le suivre.
Mais l'opération va échouer.
Derrière leurs barricades, en pleine rue,
Les putschistes se font écraser par l'armée.
16 d'entre eux seront tués.
Hitler, lui, est sain et sauf,
Mais il est arrêté puis incarcéré dans cette prison,
La forteresse de Landsberg,
Située à 60km de Munich.
Et à son arrivée, Hitler est au plus bas.
On sait qu'Hitler pesait 72 kg à son arrivée,
Et qu'il va vite perdre du poids.
Il est devenu dépressif,
Il commence une grève de la faim.
Il avait même, dit on,
Songé à se suicider après l'échec du putsch.
C'est un échec piteux et non seulement,
Il n'a pas eu l'audience qu'il voulait en Bavière,
Mais il est devenu la risée de tous les journaux.
L'histoire d'Hitler aurait pu s'arrêter là.
Et pourtant, du fond de la cellule numéro 7,
Là ou on l'attend le moins.
Il va renaître de ses cendres.
Car il le sait, il risque la peine de mort.
Alors, pour la première fois de sa vie,
Il va écrire 60 pages.
En fait, il prépare sa défense en vue de son futur procès.
De là, naît en lui l'idée de parler de ses expériences,
De ses adversaires par écrit,
Pour faire une sorte de règlement de comptes.
En 1923, c'est donc un réglement de comptes avec ses adversaires.
3 mois plus tard,
Les journalistes se bousculent à l'ouverture du procès.
Sur ce cliché historique,
Voici les conspirateurs du putsch.
Accusés de haute trahison,
Ils vont tous plaider non coupable.
Tous sauf un, qui tient tête au juge,
Adolf Hitler.
Et là,
Il se sert de ce procès comme d'une tribune.
Hitler avait du charisme et ses contemporains l'ont senti.
C'est ce qui est fatal dans ce personnage,
C'est qu'il arrivait à influencer les gens personnellement.
Les gens étaient pendus à ses lèvres.
Tout ce qu'il fantasmait, les gens le croyaient.
Finalement, Ludendorff est acquitté.
Les autres accusés obtiennent des peines minimales.
Quant à Hitler, il sort lui aussi vainqueur de ce procès.
Il risquait la peine de mort.
Il écope seulement de 5 ans de prison.
Et encore, il ne va en faire que 9 mois.
Et dans des conditions exceptionnelles.
Dans sa cellule, il a accès aux journaux.
Il boit son thé dans des tasses en porcelaine.
Avec une vue imprenable sur la campagne.
Mieux encore, habillés en civil,
Il discute avec ses codétenus.
Et parmi eux, il retrouve des amis,
Ses anciens camarades du putsch,
Comme Rudolf Hess,
Qui deviendra un des personnages clefs du troisième Reich.
Ils avaient le droit d'aller dans la salle commune quand il voulait en journée.
Ils étaient libres de leurs mouvements et libres de se parler.
C'était un peu comme une colocation entre hommes.
Dans cette prison 4 étoiles,
Hitler est traité comme une vedette.
Depuis son procès, il est devenu une petite célébrité.
Tout le monde veut le voir ou lui offrir un cadeau.
Il reçoit ainsi des biscuits,
Des fleurs,
Des lettres d'encouragement de ses fans,
Comme celle ci qui commence par,
Mon cher Führer bien aimé.
Les personnalités de la Bavière se pressent également,
Pour venir lui parler.
Le registre des visites est plein à craquer,
Tout comme ses cartes,
Qui détaillent chaque entrevue,
À la minute près.
Et parmi les 330 visiteurs,
Il y a quelques célébrités.
Le général Ludendorff,
Mais aussi la petite fille de Wagner.
Beaucoup l'incitent à continuer à écrire.
Et notamment Hélène Bechstein,
L'héritière de la marque de piano,
Va lui livrer un cadeau décisif,
Une Remington flambant neuve.
Elle lui a souvent rendu visite,
Et donc on pense que c'est bien elle,
Car c'était une machine très chère à l'époque.
Ça n'allait pas de soi d'avoir un tel appareil.
Hitler a du temps,
Son parti est à reconstruire,
Et il a besoin d'argent pour payer ses avocats.
Du coup, il se dit que rédiger un livre est peut être une bonne idée.
De là né un mythe.
Hitler, l'orateur n'aurait rien écrit.
Il aurait simplement dicté son texte à Émil Maurice et Rudolf Hess.
Or aujourd'hui, les historiens pensent le contraire.
Le Führer, a bien tapé lui même son texte en prison.
Le premier volume à Landsberg, il l'écrit seul.
De toute façon, Rudolf Hess ne savait pas très bien écrire à la machine.
Hess a appris à s'en servir en prison.
Les autres ne l'ont pas tellement aidé à ce niveau là.
Il a travaillé tout seul sur sa machine à écrire.
Cette idée qu'on a d'Hitler dictant son texte,
C'est une erreur.
C'est faux.
Hitler réécrit sa propre histoire.
Il se donne le rôle d'un héros.
Mais pas seulement.
Il profite de son incarcération pour dévorer des dizaines de livres,
Comme cet Essai sur l'inégalité des races humaines du français Gobineau.
Ou encore,
Un ouvrage au titre éloquent Rassenhygiene,
Hygiène de la race.
Aujourd'hui, cela peut sembler révoltant,
Mais à l'époque,
Ces théories pseudo scientifiques connaissent un certain succès.
Les journaux parlent de race sans aucune gêne.
Hitler va puiser là, sa source d'inspiration.
Il va en faire un collecteur.
Il va tout mettre ensemble,
Dans une espèce de brouet relativement indigeste.
Simplement, il arrive à y donner une cohérence terrible,
Cauchemardesque,
D'une lecture uniquement raciale de ces faits là.
Ainsi, au fil des mois,
Hitler va peaufiner une théorie effrayante,
Celle de la lutte des races.
Au sommet d'une pyramide imaginaire se trouvent les ariens,
Autrement dit les Allemands,
En guerre permanente pour préserver la pureté de leur race.
Leurs pires ennemis ?
Le Juif,
Considéré comme un fléau.
Il est et demeure le parasite type,
L'écornifleur, qui,
Tel un bacille nuisible, s'étend toujours plus loin.
L'effet produit par sa présence est celui des plantes parasites.
Là où il se fixe,
Le peuple qui l'accueille s'éteint au bout de plus ou moins longtemps.
Les Juifs,
Juden en allemand.
C'est un des mots les plus cités dans Mein Kampf.
Il apparaît 373 fois,
En moyenne une page sur deux.
Une obsession pour Hitler.
Selon lui,
Ils seraient responsable de tous les échecs de l'Allemagne,
Y compris la défaite de 1918.
Il essaie de convaincre les Allemands,
D'une conspiration internationale,
Derrière laquelle sont les Juifs,
Pour détruire l'Allemagne et qui explique tous leurs malheurs.
Sa seule force là dedans,
C'est de parcourir l'ensemble de l'éventail,
Du discours antisémite et de le porter à son niveau d'intensité maximale.
Fin 1924,
Hitler sort de prison avec des centaines de pages sous le bras.
Et son texte extrêmement violent à l'égard des juifs,
Il ne va avoir aucune difficulté pour le publier.
Car avec sa notoriété, les éditeurs se bousculent.
Les premiers livres commencent à sortir sur lui.
Les journaux parlent de lui.
Il était une star des médias à l'époque,
Enfin pas tout à fait une star,
Mais en tout cas quelqu'un de très connu en dehors de la Bavière,
Et même en dehors de l'Allemagne.
Et donc,
La perspective d'avoir sa première biographie,
Était très alléchante.
Hitler a le choix.
Alors il va opter pour l'éditeur qui lui promet le plus d'argent,
Max Amann.
Il se trouve en plus que c'est un ami,
Son ancien sergent, pendant la guerre de 14-18.
Il dirige une petite maison d'édition,
Et il partage les mêmes idées extrémistes.
Seulement avant de sortir le livre,
Encore faut il trouver un bon titre.
Et c'est loin d'être gagné.
Le premier titre de Mein Kampf,
C'est : Quatre ans et demi de combat contre le mensonge,
La lâcheté et la faiblesse.
Beaucoup est dit dans ce titre,
Mais en même temps,
Ce n'est pas un titre accrocheur.
Là, l'éditeur Max Amann lui dit :.
"Écoutez, ce n'est pas assez publicitaire,
Il faut faire un texte plus court !"
Plus ramassé,
Synthétique,
Et qui pourrait justement être accrocheur.
En réalité,
On ignore précisément qui a choisi le titre final.
Une chose est sûre, ce sera Mein Kampf,
Mon combat.
Et pour sa sortie,
La presse d'extrême droite multiplie les encarts publicitaires.
Le plus beau cadeau de Noël,
Assure ce journal en décembre 1925.
Mais quand il débarque en librairie, surprise,
C'est loin d'être un succès.
Quelques milliers d'exemplaires séduisent les partisans du nazisme.
Mais l'ouvrage ne perce pas autant que prévu.
Pire, certains journaux l'assassine.
"Hitler est un agitateur qui ne comprend plus le monde."
"Ces idées émanent d'un esprit dérangé."
La vérité,
C'est que Mein Kampf est un livre largement illisible.
Déjà pour les contemporains, c'est un espèce de fatras,
Espèce d'éruption volcanique,
Pas complètement maîtrisé.
Ce qui est vrai,
C'est que les attentes du public étaient liées au putsch.
On voulait des révélations sensationnelles,
Sur ce coup d'Etat.
Qu'Hitler raconte des choses secrètes.
L'attente était très forte.
Les gens espéraient voir exploser une bombe politique,
Et ça,
Ce n'était pas du tout ce qu'il y avait dans Mein Kampf.
Mais Hitler insiste.
En 1928, il rédige même un autre ouvrage,
Totalement méconnu,
Surnommé Le Livre secret.
Un pavé, là encore très agressif.
Cependant, ce deuxième livre ne sera jamais imprimé de son vivant.
L'éditeur le refuse car les ventes de Mein Kampf ne sont guère brillantes.
Ainsi, le livre fétiche d'Hitler aurait pu en rester là,
Et n'être qu'un opuscule confidentiel.
Seulement, son destin est sur le point de basculer.
Nous sommes en 1930,
La crise économique américaine frappe l'Allemagne de plein fouet.
Un pays déjà affaibli.
En l'espace de 4 ans,
Le pays compte 4 millions de chômeurs en plus.
Aux élections,
Les Allemands boudent les partis classiques et votent pour les extrêmes.
Le parti d'Hitler passe de 3 à 18%.
Aussitôt, les ventes de Mein Kampf s'envolent.
54 000 exemplaires vendus rien qu'en 1930.
On veut savoir ce que pense,
Ce que veut cet Hitler,
Qui s'est inscrit maintenant dans le paysage politique allemand.
Et puis, dans sa quête du pouvoir,
Ce livre va améliorer l'image du führer.
Ça assoit la crédibilité d'Hitler,
Qui n'est plus seulement un agitateur,
Qui n'est plus seulement un tribun,
Mais qui est également un écrivain.
Et ça, c'est quelque chose en Allemagne qui comptait.
L'allemagne est un pays qui encore aujourd'hui,
Révère les Herr Doktor ou Herr Professor.
1933,
Hitler étonne le monde entier.
Il parvient au sommet du pouvoir presque par surprise.
Il est nommé chancelier.
Seulement, sa légitimité ne repose que sur 37% des voix.
Or, pour réaliser ses rêves de grandeur et de conquête,
Contenue dans Mein Kampf,
Il va avoir besoin d'une Allemagne unie.
Alors, avec l'aide de Goebbels,
Il va mettre en place une des théories de son livre,
La propagande.
Toute propagande efficace doit se limiter à des points forts peu nombreux,
Et les faire valoir à coup de formules stéréotypées aussi longtemps qu'il le faudra.
Jusqu'à ce que le dernier des auditeurs soit à même de saisir l'idée.
Et un des outils de cette propagande de masse,
Ce sera bien sûr Mein Kampf.
Très vite,
L'Etat recommande aux fonctionnaires de l'acheter.
À partir de 1936,
Les mairies l'offrent aux jeunes mariés.
Et puis le führer séduit les industriels.
Grâce au réarmement,
Leurs commandes sont multipliées par 8.
Alors, des entreprises comme, Krupp,
Le distribuent à tour de bras.
On le recevait pour des anniversaires ou des fêtes.
Ou alors il était donné comme on distribue une prime ou un bonus,
En cas de bonne performance.
Et pour booster ses ventes,
L'éditeur décline le livre sous tous les formats.
Édition en braille pour les aveugles.
Version de luxe avec couverture en marbre,
Tranchant des pages plaqué or,
Une série limitée pour les hauts dignitaires nazis.
Et nec plus ultra de la propagande,
Une énorme version en format bible.
C'était un symbole de domination pour les national socialistes.
On le considérait comme la bible du nazisme.
Et ce qui était encore plus important que le livre en lui même,
C'était la fonction symbolique.
Le fait qu'on dise Mein Kampf,
On connaît,
C'est le livre du Führer.
Le livre devient par la force un best-seller.
De quoi assurer la fortune d'Hitler.
Avec ses droits d'auteur,
Il va gagner l'équivalent de dizaines de millions d'euros.
Il peut s'offrir son fameux nid d'aigle,
Le Berghof,
Et assouvir son goût pour les luxueuses Mercedes.
En tout,
12 millions et demi d'exemplaires ont été imprimés en Allemagne,
Jusqu'en 1944.
Et pour chaque exemplaire,
Hitler gagnait environ un Reichsmark.
Cela veut dire qu'il a gagné avec ce livre,
Au moins 12 millions et demi de Reichsmark.
Seulement derrière ces distributions massives.
Mein Kampf est-il vraiment lu ?
Pas sûr,
Avec ses 700 pages et son texte ardu,
Où l'ouvrage a de quoi rebuter.
En 1940,
Karl-Heinz Rine est enrôlé dans la Wehrmacht comme infirmier.
Dans sa famille, son père avait bien reçu un exemplaire par son entreprise,
Mais ce cadeau ne lui plaisait guère.
Mon père, a mis le livre sur une étagère.
Et il est resté là jusqu'en 1945.
Mon père a regardé à l'intérieur,
Et il a dit que c'était une pure déclaration de guerre.
Et il a rajouté :
"Je ne lirais pas ces bêtises."
En fait, à l'époque, comme beaucoup d'autres Allemands,
Karl et son père sous estime Hitler.
Hitler,
On ne l'a pas pris au sérieux.
Un homme qui écrit une chose pareille,
On ne pensait pas qu'il resterait au pouvoir.
Et puis on faisait des blagues sur lui,
On se moquait de lui.
Finalement, c'est vrai,
On aurait peut être dû le prendre au sérieux.
Dans d'autres familles, en revanche,
Le livre cristallise toutes les peurs.
Dans la banlieue Est de Berlin,
Au bord de la Sprée,
Lutz Rackow,
Se souvient parfaitement de la première fois qu'il a entendu parler de Mein Kampf.
En 1938, Lutz n'avait que 6 ans.
Son père, Otto, était architecte.
Un soir,
Il réunit des amis chez lui pour leur parler du livre d'Hitler.
J'étais assis sous la table au lieu d'être au lit,
Car j'étais curieux de ce qu'il se disait.
Et j'entendais en boucle mon père leur dire,
"Mais lisez donc ce livre, lisez ce livre."
Et évidemment, il ne parlait pas de la Bible,
Ou de quelque chose d'autre, mais de Mein Kampf.
Lutz ignore si les amis de son père ont suivi son conseil.
Mais une chose est sûre,
Son père était un des rares Allemands,
À avoir conscience des catastrophes annoncées,
Dans le livre phare des nazis.
Il était d'avis,
Que toutes les réponses étaient dans Mein Kampf.
Tout ce que les nazis allaient entreprendre.
À cette époque,
Ce dont je me rappelle,
C'est qu'Hitler parlait de liberté,
Liberté,
Liberté.
Et en réalité, il préparait la guerre de toutes ses forces !
Et bien sûr,
Cette guerre en préparation doit rester entièrement secrète.
Et c'est justement ce qui commence à embarrasser Hitler.
Il a peur que ses projets soient déjà dévoilés dans son livre.
En effet, certains passages annoncent de futures conquêtes.
Le but de notre politique extérieure,
Assurer au peuple allemand le territoire qui lui revient en ce monde.
Le territoire justifiera le sacrifice de nos propres enfants.
Et dans sa soif d'espace vital.
Hitler cible un pays en particulier,
La France.
L'ennemi mortel,
L'ennemi impitoyable du peuple allemand est et reste la France.
Mein Kampf, prévoit l'idée d'une revanche contre la France,
Une revanche militaire.
Et par ailleurs,
Il y a dans Mein Kampf des pages,
D'une très grande violence contre la France,
Qui est considérée comme finalement le symbole du métissage racial.
Un pays de nègres,
C'est le mot qui est utilisé par Hitler et un pays de juifs.
Et si les Français prenait au sérieux ses menaces,
Ils pourraient empêcher le réarmement de l'Allemagne.
Alors Hitler va adopter une stratégie très culottée.
Novembre 1933, à Berlin, le Führer reçoit un journaliste français,
Fernand de Brinon,
Un partisan du rapprochement avec l'Allemagne.
Il parle allemand et a sans doute déjà lu des passages de Mein Kampf.
Et là, Hitler va lui livrer un scoop.
La toute première interview française du nouveau chancelier.
Et quand De Brinon interroge le Führer sur ses déclarations anti-françaises,
Inscrites dans son livre,
Hitler va utiliser une ruse,
Vieille comme le monde,
Le mensonge.
Hitler explique qu'il ne veut que la paix,
Qu'il est lui même un ancien combattant,
Que l'Europe a trop souffert.
Et évidemment,
Brinon est obligée de lui poser la question que beaucoup se posent.
Parce qu'effectivement Mein Kampf est connu en lui disant,
Mais écoutez dans Mein Kampf ce n'est pas les propos que vous tenez.
Dans Mein Kampf,
Ce ne sont pas des propos de paix à l'endroit de la France,
Au contraire, ce sont des propos de guerre.
Et là, Hitler a cette réponse en expliquant,
"J'ai changé",
Comme le ferait finalement aujourd'hui un homme politique,
Qui serait face à un texte de jeunesse.
J'ai changé,
J'ai écrit ce texte alors que j'étais en prison,
Dans l'emportement de ce moment là et aujourd'hui je suis chancelier.
L'interview fera la une du journal Le Matin,
Un des grands quotidiens de l'époque.
Avec une déclaration du Führer qui se veut rassurante.
"La guerre ne réglerait rien,
Elle ne ferait qu'empirer l'état du monde."
Mais en France,
Un homme n'en croit pas un mot,
Et va tout faire pour combattre le livre d'Hitler.
Cet homme, c'est Fernand Sorlot,
Un éditeur qui commence à percer dans le Paris des années 30.
Fernand Sorlot est un éditeur modeste,
Ces Nouvelles Éditions latines publient des essais,
En rapport avec l'actualité politique.
Il publie beaucoup de textes politiques,
Mais il publie beaucoup de littérature.
C'est le quatrième ou le cinquième éditeur,
D'auteurs de romans étrangers.
Fernand Sorlot, homme de droite,
Admire alors Mussolini.
Mais Hitler et son ouvrage fétiche l'inquiètent beaucoup.
C'est en tout cas le souvenir que garde François-Xavier Sorlot,
L'un des fils de l'éditeur.
Les 30 ou 40% du texte sont anti-français.
C'est vraiment une attaque, si vous voulez,
Sur le pays.
Alors lui, il n'a pas fait 14.
Il était trop jeune,
Mais il avait rencontré ma mère déjà à l'époque,
Et je veux dire ma mère était très anti-allemande,
Puisque mon grand père maternel avait été tué tout de suite à la guerre de 14.
Sorlot aimerait bien imprimer le livre d'Hitler,
Pour alerter les Français.
Et dans le même temps pour réaliser un bon coup commercial.
Problème, cela risque de lui coûter cher.
Il y a 700 pages à traduire.
Et surtout Max Amann et Hitler refusent toute traduction en français.
Mein Kampf regorgeant de passages anti-français,
Il est évidemment absolument inenvisageable,
Que la version non expurgée du texte soit diffusée en français.
Fernand Sorlot, est donc dans une impasse.
Jusqu'au jour, où il est convoqué au ministère des Anciens Combattants.
Là, il est reçu en toute discrétion.
Une opération secrète se prépare.
Sorlot est mis en contact avec un personnage,
Un juif, ancien combattant,
Qui s'appelle Maurice Vanikoff,
Et qui va l'introduire dans les milieux ministériels,
Le ministère des Anciens Combattants,
Et c'est par le biais de ce ministère qu'une équipe,
Mais officieusement bien sûr,
Va être rassemblé.
Sorlot se lance alors dans une course contre la montre.
Il veut traduire au plus vite Mein Kampf en français.
Et pour y arriver,
Le ministère fournit 7 traducteurs chevronnés.
Mieux encore, la LICA,
La Ligue contre l'antisémitisme,
Lui achète 5000 exemplaires,
Soit 50 000 francs en faveur de Sorlot.
Ce qui est un rôle absolument déterminant,
Puisqu'on voit bien que dans une opération comme celle là,
Qui doit être menée rapidement,
Il faut que les choses aillent vite.
Il faut mobiliser de l'argent et elle a su le faire.
L'ouvrage sort en février 1934 avec un slogan choc,
"Tout Français doit lire ce livre."
Et même sens de la formule avec cette affiche publicitaire.
Elle joue sur la peur qu'inspire Mein Kampf,
Et prophétise,
Une deuxième guerre viendra.
Sorlot a réussi un joli coup d'édition.
Seulement, l'affaire va prendre une autre tournure.
Hitler est furieux.
Le petit éditeur français est en train de ruiner sa propagande.
Hitler, évidemment,
Ne veut pas que les Français aient accès à son texte,
Sans le truchement de sa propagande et de ses discours de circonstance.
Hitler à cette époque là est dans une offensive,
Pseudo pacifique,
Où il clame sur tous les toits à qui veut bien l'entendre,
Je suis pacifique, je ne veux pas la guerre, etc.
Mein Kampf, de ce point de vue là,
L'ennuie.
C'est une épine dans son pied.
Alors le chancelier attaque Sorlot en justice.
L'affaire va se dérouler, ici à Paris,
Au tribunal de commerce.
Le 5 juin 1934,
Les avocats allemands et français s'affrontent.
Droit d'alerter l'opinion publique contre droits d'auteur.
Sorlot, contre l'homme le plus puissant d'Allemagne.
La sentence tombe 13 jours plus tard.
Et elle peut paraître incroyablement choquante.
La justice française donne raison au dictateur.
Interdiction de faire imprimer, vendre,
Ou de faire vendre Mein Kampf,
Sous astreinte de 100 francs par infraction.
Les livres existants doivent être détruits.
Mais le français n'en fera rien.
Il va contourner la loi avec des versions abrégée,
Autrement dit, des éditions pirates,
Édités sans l'autorisation de l'auteur.
En prime,
Il va même réussir à écouler son stock avec la complicité des forces de l'ordre.
Il a vendu un nombre de livres assez considérable pendant cette période,
Même après condamnation du tribunal,
Parce que les Allemands se plaignaient que le livre soit toujours en vente,
Donc demandant des saisies chez l'éditeur.
Et mon père recevait un coup de téléphone du commissariat du quartier,
Pour lui dire :
"On va venir saisir chez vous pour voir si vous continuez à vendre le livre."
Et hop, on mettait les livres dans un camion, me disait-il.
Et la police venait, il n'y avait plus rien.
Et le soir, le camion rentrait et le lendemain, on recommençait.
En revanche Sorlot va échouer sur un point.
Le livre n'alarme en aucun cas les élites françaises.
Même les 4000 exemplaires distribués par la LICA n'ont aucun effet.
Les décideurs sont aveuglés par les propos pacifistes d'Hitler.
Pour eux, le livre est trop violent pour être réel.
Il est impensable,
De mener la politique qui est annoncée dans Mein Kampf.
Donc, on pense qu'Hitler mettra de l'eau dans son vin.
Donc il y a un refus de voir,
Non seulement la violence qu'il y a dans Mein Kampf,
Vaut mieux l'ignorer, politique de l'autruche,
Mais aussi un refus de comprendre que la culture politique allemande,
Fait qu'Hitler fera ce qu'il dit.
En attendant, les idées du livre, elles,
Pénètrent progressivement les esprits,
Dans les rues ou sur les ondes.
Goebbels, ministre de la Propagande,
Fait lire des extraits de Mein Kampf.
Le Reich développe même un poste radio à bas prix,
Pour entrer dans tous les foyers.
Et à l'école,
Certains enseignants prônent le culte du führer.
Les enfants le chantent,
Ils sont prêts à vivre et à mourir pour Hitler,
Leur sauveur,
L'esprit le plus noble d'Allemagne.
En fait, Hitler met en pratique ce qu'il avait écrit dans son livre.
Ainsi, sa haine des juifs s'affiche au grand jour.
"Allemand ! Ton ennemi est le juif " indique cet écriteau.
Les journaux regorgent de caricatures choquantes,
Montrant des juifs sous des traits monstrueux,
En train de contrôler le monde.
Et à force de marteler ce rejet des juifs.
Certains finissent par adopter ce terrible discours.
Je sais qu'un jour mon frère est rentré en pleurant de l'école,
Et ma mère lui a demandé pourquoi il était triste.
Mon frère a répondu que Monsieur ****, qui était juif,
Lui avait donné des bonbons.
Et les autres enfants ont dit à mon frère :
"Celui qui mange de la main des juifs va mourir !"
J'ai entendu l'histoire et je me suis dit :
"Je n'ai pas de bonbons, alors je ne suis pas en danger."
De manière perverse, insidieuse,
L'antisémitisme s'installe en Allemagne.
Mais pour autant,
La Shoah est-elle programmée dans Mein Kampf ?
Pour une fois, les historiens sont unanimes.
Alors évidemment,
Mein Kampf n'annonce pas les chambres à gaz, certes.
Mais sur ce point là, par exemple,
Mein Kampf théorise à longueur de pages,
Le fait que l'Allemagne est engagée dans un combat à mort,
Dont il peut y avoir qu'un seul vainqueur,
Entre le peuple allemand racialement pur et les juifs, par exemple.
Les Allemands devaient être au courant,
De ce que Hitler avait prévu, grosso modo,
Avec ou sans Mein Kampf.
Hitler n'a jamais laissé de doute sur le fait qu'il voulait,
Modifier le traité de Versailles et prendre sa revanche sur la France.
Et ça, dans l'esprit de quelqu'un de raisonné,
Cela ne peut être qu'en lien avec la guerre.
Mais comment la guerre allait être menée ?
Contre qui ?
Quel avenir il réservait aux pays de l'Est ?
Ça, ce n'était pas écrit dans son livre Mein.
Jusqu'au bout,
Jusqu'à la veille de la guerre,
Les Européens vont s'accrocher à l'idée d'une paix possible avec le Führer.
Octobre 1938,
Hitler annonce qu'il va annexer la Tchécoslovaquie.
Il s'agit d'une violation des frontières définies en 1918.
L'europe est au bord de la guerre et tout va se jouer ici à Munich.
Le Premier ministre britannique Neville Chamberlain,
Et le ministre de la Défense Édouard Daladier y sont dépêchés en urgence.
Finalement,
Il préfère abandonner l'allié tchèque,
En échange d'une promesse de paix de la part d'Hitler.
Il signe alors les fameux accords de Munich.
À leur retour,
Le Français et le Britannique vont être accueillis en héros.
Ce matin,
J'ai eu une nouvelle discussion avec le chancelier allemand,
Hitler.
Et j'ai ici un papier qui porte son nom et le mien.
L'accord signé la nuit dernière et l'accord anglo germanique naval,
Symbolise le désir de nos 2 peuples de ne jamais entrer un jour en guerre.
La paix semble sauvée.
"Ne vous souciez pas du clair, partez en vacances."
Conseille La Presse.
Quel est le politique qui avait envie de dire :
"Je déclare la guerre !" ?
Quelle est le politicien qui avait envie de dire :.
"Je vais faire la guerre !" ?
La majorité des sociétés européennes sont pacifistes,
Plus jamais la guerre,
Plus jamais la Première Guerre mondiale,
Plus jamais la boucherie.
Et même après Munich,
Rares sont les élites à pressentir la guerre inscrite dans Mein Kampf.
Churchill ou le jeune colonel de Gaulle l'ont lu très tôt.
Ils se disent atterrés, mais à l'époque,
Ils ne sont pas en position de force.
Mais de Gaulle n'est pas aux affaires.
En Angleterre, Churchill.
Mais il est devenu une sorte de marginal dans les années 30.
En 1939, ce discours pacifiste,
Minutieusement entretenu,
S'effondre brutalement.
L'Allemagne attaque la Pologne.
Et ne tarde pas à envahir une bonne partie de l'Europe.
Les troupes du Reich défilent à Paris.
Hitler jubile.
Le monde entier tremble à l'idée de passer sous le joug des nazis.
À ce moment là,
Les élites révisent leur jugement sur Mein Kampf.
Mein Kampf,
On découvre sa nocivité et on découvre que,
Hitler met en œuvre la politique qu'il a annoncé.
Il y a une découverte,
De ce qui existait déjà,
Mais qu'on n'avait pas vu,
Ou qu'on n'avait pas voulu voir.
C'est alors que le destin du livre va subitement changer.
Avant 1939, les Alliés n'ont pas vu en lui le danger.
Désormais, ils vont en faire un épouvantail,
L'objet d'une contre propagande efficace.
Et ça se passe aux États-Unis.
Là bas, les Américains manifestent contre la guerre.
L'homme de la rue n'est guère emballé,
À l'idée d'aller délivrer l'Europe.
Une autre guerre ? Pas pour moi.
Cette fois, l'Amérique ne devrait pas y aller.
En ce qui concerne la guerre en Europe,
Je pense qu'on devrait rester en dehors de ce conflit.
Pour moi, c'est non.
Oui, combattons !
Non !
Alors les autorités diffusent des spot comme celui ci.
La scène se déroule dans une église,
À l'heure de la messe.
Pour mobiliser les troupes,
Le film s'adresse aux minorités dénigrées dans le livre.
Mein Kampf devient alors une arme de persuasion.
Je ne vais pas tous vous lire,
Mais il y a une ou deux choses qui devraient vous intéresser dans ce livre.
Je cite :
"De temps en temps, les journaux illustrés,
Montrent comment un nègre est devenu avocat,
Professeur et parfois même ministre.
Il n'apparaît pas à l'Amérique dégénéré,
Que cela soit véritablement un péché contre la raison.
Une folie criminelle que d'entraîner quelqu'un né à moitié singe,
À croire qu'on a fait de lui un avocat."
Ce livre a été écrit il y a 20 ans.
Et le plan qu'il poursuit est devenu réalité.
Dans le même temps, de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique,
La propagande autour du livre s'intensifie.
La guerre est aussi une bataille d'idées.
Et pour l'emporter,
Le Reich veut imposer son évangile nazi dans les écoles.
Mais cette fois,
L'opération se déroule dans les territoires conquis.
C'est une page d'histoire peu connue.
Une partie de la France va se trouver nazifiée.
Il s'agit de l'Alsace et de la Moselle.
À partir de 1940,
Ces 2 départements redeviennent allemands.
Et là, l'enseignement va être bouleversé.
C'est ce que nous avons découvert,
Aux Archives départementales d'Alsace,
À travers le témoignage de Marguerite Forster.
Cette institutrice alsacienne tient un journal intime.
Et dès l'été 1940, elle note, angoissée :
"Qu'arrivera t-il avec moi et mes collègues ?
Je déteste du fond du cœur les méthodes allemandes.
Je suis révoltée à la pensée que je devrais faire,
L'éducation d'une jeunesse hitlérienne.
Leur apprendre à penser,
Deutschland über alles,
Allemagne au dessus de tous.
Il faudra leur découvrir toutes les fautes de la France,
Leur apprendre peut être à la détester en ennemie.
Tout mon être proteste contre cet état de choses.
Mon Dieu, que votre volonté se fasse."
Marguerite a beau protester,
Elle doit appliquer,
Comme tous ses confrères d'Alsace-Moselle,
Les consignes du Reich.
Elle va donc se rendre en Allemagne,
Pour subir un endoctrinement.
Là bas,
Elle doit apprendre ce programme intitulé Raffentunde,
La science des races.
La lecture de Mein Kampf y est obligatoire.
Et dans son carnet,
Margueritte écrit en allemand,
Ce que les nazis lui dictent au sujet de la musique.
"Le Juif n'a pas d'activité créatrice,
Il prend la créativité aux autres.
La musique juive va faire entrer l'Europe dans la nuit."
Pour ses élèves,
Elle doit désormais utiliser ce livre pro-nazi.
À l'intérieur,
Hitler figure en bonne position parmi les auteurs à étudier.
Dans leurs cahiers,
Suivant les instructions de leurs professeurs,
Les élèves de 8 à 10 ans dessinent des symboles nazis.
L'instite, faisait le salut hitlérien en arrivant le matin.
Tous les cours, tous les matins,
Démarraient avec un bilan du front,
Où en étaient l'armée allemande.
Est-ce qu'il y a des avancées ?
Est-ce qu'il y a des reculs ?
Et il ne faut pas oublier,
Qu'il y avait aussi des instituteurs allemands,
Qui étaient envoyés en Alsace et en Moselle,
Dont certains ont appliqué les programmes avec beaucoup de zèle.
À partir de 1944,
L'armée allemande accumule les défaites.
Et plus le temps passe,
Plus le livre phare du régime devient un objet encombrant.
Pour éviter de passer pour des nazis,
Les Allemands cherchent désormais à s'en débarrasser.
Le plus grand nombre d'exemplaires que j'ai vus,
C'était le 23 avril 1945.
On avait un terrain à côté de la Sprée,
Et j'ai vu énormément d'exemplaires qui flottaient sur l'eau.
C'était du poison.
Il fallait s'en débarrasser.
Et donc les voisins ont jeté dans un trou tout ce qui était empoisonné.
Les armes et les livres devenus gênants.
Et dont tout ce fatras, il y avait plusieurs Mein Kampf,
On les voyait comme le nez au milieu de la figure,
Avec leur couverture rouge.
On a recouvert tout ça de terre,
Et après on a prié nos anges gardiens pour que personne ne les découvre.
Évidemment, avec l'avancée de l'Armée rouge.
Les gens avaient peur de subir des contrôles,
Ou d'être identifiés comme des gens possédant ce livre.
Ils craignaient que les Russes se retournent contre eux.
C'est pour cela qu'ils s'en débarrasser.
Dorénavant, dans l'Allemagne vaincue,
Tous les symboles nazis doivent disparaître.
Les alliés l'exigent.
Les plaques qui ont servi à imprimer Mein Kampf doivent être détruites.
Toute réédition du livre maudit est fermement interdite en Allemagne.
À ce moment là,
Personne n'imagine que ce best-seller,
Va se transformer en long-seller.
Son auteur est mort.
Son œuvre est pétrie de haine.
Sa politique a abouti à une effroyable hécatombe.
Et pourtant, son pamphlet interdit va continuer d'être publié.
En France, par exemple, après la guerre,
Sorlot va imprimer Mein Kampf jusqu'à aujourd'hui,
En moyenne 2000 exemplaires par an.
Et il n'est pas le seul.
My Struggle en Angleterre.
A Minha Luta au Brésil.
Wǒ de Zhàndòu en Chine.
Le livre est publié dans le monde entier,
Et ce depuis les années 30.
Impossible d'interdire sa parution,
Surtout à l'heure du Web.
Ainsi, depuis 1945,
Des millions d'exemplaires auraient été vendus.
Mein Kampf continue d'être lu et évidemment de susciter la curiosité.
Parce qu'évidemment, le nazisme,
Le troisième Reich, Hitler,
Fascine.
Vous avez aussi la fascination pour ce qui est interdit.
C'est interdit, donc ça doit y avoir des trucs intéressants,
Donc on va le chercher.
Dans les pays arabes en lutte contre Israël,
Le livre séduit les antisémites.
Plus surprenant, Kavgam,
La version turque devient numéro 1 des ventes du pays en 2005.
Près de 100 000 exemplaires écoulés en 2 mois,
Quand les nationalistes accèdent au pouvoir.
Même succès étonnant en Inde,
Où Hitler est parfois cité dans les écoles de management,
Comme un modèle de réussite.
Un pays comme l'Inde,
Où Mein Kampf depuis des années et depuis des décennies même,
Connaît un succès.
C'est que Mein Kampf,
C'est aussi un symbole d'un ultra nationalisme belliciste,
Et qui, au nom d'une communauté,
Finalement s'impose et s'impose à ses voisins.
Depuis le 1ᵉʳ janvier 2016,
Le livre entame un nouveau chapitre de son histoire.
Conformément à la loi sur les droits d'auteur,
L'ouvrage tombe dans le domaine public.
En théorie, plus rien ne s'oppose à sa réédition.
Mais en Allemagne, le livre est encore considéré comme dangereux.
Du coup, seules les éditions critiques comme celles ci sont autorisées.
Le texte du Führer est encadré par 3500 commentaires,
Rédigés par des historiens.
Naturellement,
Nous voulons réaliser une édition critique.
Une édition basée sur les fondamentaux.
Il s'agit de contredire Hitler,
De le corriger.
En France,
Les éditions Fayard ont entrepris la même démarche.
Un comité scientifique prépare une version,
Elle aussi commentée,
Histoire de désamorcer la haine et les mensonges du texte originel.